in 1968 there was a civil war in Nigeria
a bit of Nigeria the eastern province
wished to break away and set up an
independent state court which they
wanted to call bafreux that didn't
happen there was a civil war and it led
to a very significant famine and it was
the images of that famine coming back to
Ireland and we didn't we hadn't had
television for too long a television in
Ireland was only brought in in 1961 and
so the images of for many Irish people
baffler was what they call the first
family on television so those images
were coming into the households and
people were responding but there's
another factor which was important in
those days many many Irish missionaries
worked in Africa particularly worked in
that area in Nigeria called by Aphra so
almost every community in Ireland knew
somebody who was already there as a
priest or a nun and so that added to you
know I supposed to shock the outrage of
seeing what what was happening there and
that gave rise to a most extraordinary
outpouring of generosity at the time and
it led to the establishment of an
organization called Africa concern which
was the forerunner of the organisation
which became concerned so that's the
story about how concern started it went
on from there and this is for Bangladesh
became important because Bangladesh was
create was just created as a state
couple of years later and then concern
was in there at the very beginning also
and over the next few years a lot of
Irish young Irish Volunteers went to
work in Bangladesh in and they I think
created the the you know the foundation
of support for the organization
throughout Ireland which you know which
remains to this to this day
I think the if
act of the irish famine in the
mid-nineteen 19th century from 1845
predict through to eighteen forty-eight
forty-nine the consequences it had a
million people left the shores million
people died million people emigrated it
had a profound impact on the re psyche
and and I think it's one of the reasons
why there's been almost an extraordinary
empathy on behalf of the Irish people
with poor people in other parts of the
world and i think it is part of the
reason why organizations like concern
has had such support from the irish
people over the over the 40 years of its
existence i think the other factor
though which is important is the irish
missionary trans tradition and again
that really started in really from the
from the second half of the 19th century
and over at the following hundred years
there were many many thousands of irish
men and women went to work on the
missions and they would have brought
back stories they would have reflected
back the realities of life in all over
the world not just Africa Asia Latin
America and so on so there was I think a
certain basic understanding on the part
of many are his people and basic
sympathy for as a result of those
stories and so they that I think is very
key to understanding the the
underpinning of support at for NGOs like
concern but also the fact that Ireland
is one of the relatively few countries
in the world this stage that has made a
formal commitment to reach the UN aid
target of giving 0.7 percent of its
national income by 2012 and that's based
on a very strong cross party political
consensus within Ireland and that in
turn I think goes back to the factors
that I already spoke about the famine
and the missionary tradition
you